صوت مجلس النواب العراقي اليوم بالاغلبيه
على قانون الموازنه الاتحاديه للعام
الجاري وللعامين المقبلين في جلسه بدات في
ساعه متاخره من الليله الماضيه وامتدت حتى
ساعه الفجر واستغرق التصويت على مواد
الموازنه 4 جلسات برلمانيه متتاليه بسبب
الخلافات
بين القوى السياسيه بشان الفقرات المتعلقه
باقليم كردستان
وايراداته النفطيه وتوزيع رواتب الموظفين
في الاقليم ياتي هذا التصويت بعد خلاف
بشان اليه توزيع الواردات الماليه من
تصدير النفط من اقليم كردستان العراق
والاستخدامها حصرا في عمليه وبعد التصويت
عبر الزعيم الكردي ورئيس الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني مسعود البرزاني عن اسفه لتصديق
البرلمان على قانون الموازنه وقال ان ما
حدث داخل البرلمان محاولات غير مسؤوله
وغير دستوريه تهدف الى تعميق المشاكل
وانتهاك الحقوق المشروعه للشعب الكردستاني
واضاف البرزاني في بيان ان الموافقه على
القانون جاء خلافا للاتفاق الذي ابرم في
وقت سابق بين حكومه الاقليم وحكومه بغداد
وقال انه يعارض وبشده اي محاوله تسعى
لتجاوز وتقويض كيان اقليم كردستان مؤكدا
ان اقليم كردستان ليس خطا احمر فحسب بل هو
خط الموت وفق تعبيره